massive entertainment these are
dangerous times a Ubisoft Studio at
least that's what I hear a TIE fighter
Zips through a Starship battle the
Empire a shot takes out the tie in a
fiery explosion they're everywhere a
star destroyer appears out of hyperspace
and an opposing Starship crashes into it
but the world here a body in carbonite
Glides away from a hot family member
sending in the fog a figure brings down
a sword on a smaller being Lucas film
games in a Cantina a young brunette
plays sabak with a group of aliens I
wanna survive
yeah I have to play their game under the
table she signals a small creature with
a gecko-like face who peeks at her
opponent's cards then returns to her
looks like I'm all in now a bounty
hunter shows her image to the bartender
who points to the brunette she's in here
somewhere one second thought I'm out her
creature diverts an opponent's Blaster
fire which hits a Burly alien at the bar
a fight breaks out
the Bounty Hunter shoots at the brunette
who dashes through the melee and escapes
with her creature at her heels
as the Bounty Hunter and a few others
shoot at her she runs to a Speeder Bike
parked among ship parts climbing on she
zooms away out running explosions at her
back
I've been held back my whole life she
races through a crowded street with her
creature staying close and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
in a cave the brunette Shields her eyes
from daylight pouring in wherever that
takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
give me a chance
you're gonna have to trust me it'll be
dangerous risky but if you pull this off
you'll never look over your shoulder
again in slow motion case shoots down a
pursuer from her speeder bike in a pit a
Rancor races its clawed hands standing
on the edge of a Terrace a bearded man
in a fur Cape glowers the underworld
shows no mercy on the edge of a cliff K
looks through macro binoculars but it's
a big Galaxy out there and I'm gonna
risk it off
in the Starship battle K Twirls and
weaves her ship around exploding vessels
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024.